simplement
[Musique]
tu pars tu as quel âge est-on savane
oui 113 ans l'âge de 12 ans monsieur
riche carrière j'ai vécu avec lui mais
ça fait cinq ans avec lui n'étaient pas
mariés initial de 25 ans avait 12 ans
prospecter les gens aujourd'hui
[Musique]
d
j'ai beaucoup vécu quand même temps au
total avec rutten camps s'emploieraient
mais à l'époque où tu dit avec lui
c'était comme un garçon
non à 15 étaient déjà très si c'était
déjà traversé excellent parce que
maintenant c'est la mode en palestine
à mon époque on disait avertis c'est
quoi la différence entre aventure qu'on
sait maintenant on dit qu' un travesti
ce garçon qui se déguise en femme
village et nyanga sont là enfin bon
sexuelle contre comme je vis tout le
temps mais dans dix mois après comment
tu la quittes et ce trip cet héritage il
a tué non il y fut noyé
cécile était pas mort pour et contre
l'avis de ranrupt la main c'est le
premier amour
ça aurait pu passer toute ta vie avec
mon riz un bon et voir comment t'es
venue en france
on n'a pas le temps pas mal pour
produire un rapport d'assainir
paris et toutes les plaintes et les
rêves et des vignes à paris arrive dès
qu'on dit transsexuels on pense à
brésilien oui c'est parce qu'en fait
c'est pas parce qu'on a toutes les
capitales c'est pas pareil à paris est
là plus qu'ailleurs il a plus qu'à
londres où il y en a plus qu'un oui et
l'as rome et disons rien à compte avec
un sexe elle est elle bien
bah ouais les français tu suces et
j'étais le père d'accueil la france m'a
personnellement je suis dynamique à
dépenser ses débuts à quel âge ici
[Musique]
satan comment tu vis en france parce que
tu fais des fêtes spectacle les galas
une mutation comme neige comme ça on
peut enfin cisco tech
je comprends ça va alléger encore là oui
j'aime une famille est prévu que mr bah
oui tu rencontres un garçon si oui il ya
longtemps que j'avais depuis maintenant
ça fait
bientôt sept ans à bâtir ont fait à
chaque fois c'est vachement long c'était
très agréable à tous les hommes qui sont
avec miley on vit avec moi parce que
l'on sait dangereux spectatrice très
discret et alors dit moi
face à un peu personnel comme question
mais toi tu être toujours travers cela
est plein d'excès transférer 10 et 1 500
femmes du même âge oui je sais ça te
fait opérer ou non maroc
beaucoup de gens yanina pas pourquoi des
de travail parce que
al angeles au musée décline il est temps
de passer à 6 4 mais durant 10 jours la
grève a coûté 4 mais voilà quatre buts
alors que j'ai confiance et qu'il a
offert un petit plus tu regrettes pas
des choix de quoi ne pas être resté un
garçon mayrand
c'est très bien comme l'esprit mais je
pense que c'est parce que tout est comme
ça quand tu es né ou c'est parce que
tous les besoins d'argent à un moment
non non parce que c'est moi je voulais
vraiment là je te découvre tous les
jours gras sexuelle brésilien qui vient
en france et vont tout seul oui moi je
n'ai pas j'adore le dit sa mise en jeu
dans fait leur travail et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux